Hi there, my name is Carl and I'd like
to welcome you to SQL for data analysis.
An SQL database is a valuable tool for
managing, organizing, and
querying your data.
By the end of this course,
you'll be able to do all this using data
in your own local relational database.
You'll master the basics of SQL,
the language for querying and
populating databases.
Let's have a look at what you'll
be doing throughout each lesson of
the course.
In the first lesson you'll learn
some important concepts about how
we organize data in
relational databases.
In the second lesson, you'll learn
how to use SQL to fetch data out of
a database and insert new data into it.
And in third lesson, you'll define new
tables, perform more advanced queries
and extend the power of your analysis
by connecting python to your database.
After each lesson there's
an optional problem set.
These are meant to help you gain even
more familiarity with the SQL language,
while setting up your
own local database.
If you're in the data analyst program,
this problem sets also focus on getting
you prepared for one of the projects.
To finish this project you'll need to be
able to define schemas, import data, and
perform queries on data from
the open street maps dataset.
After this course that's
exactly you'll be able to do.
Okay great, let's get started.